[Musica]
parto avvantaggiato sono fortunato
perché con un cognome così putano già
controverso abbastanza per parlarne per
ore purtroppo non è il tempo
oggi vi voglio parlare invece di un
argomento che ci accomuna un po tutti
ovvero scelte controverse e felicità
chi di voi si è accorto che da adulti è
un tantino più difficile essere felici
rispetto a quando eravamo bambini sulla
mano questa foto che vedete alle mie
spalle è fotografo ha probabilmente uno
degli istanti più felici della mia
infanzia e non perché era successo
chissà che cosa dice chissà cosa era
accaduto avevo appena ricevuto una
mountain bike la bicicletta è quello
bastava per rendere di me il bambino più
felice del probabilmente quartiere io
crescevo putano non è un cognome sardo
come potrebbe sembrare come spesso mi
hanno confuso ma sono nato e cresciuto
in romania per i primi dieci anni della
mia vita
e questi primi dieci anni sono stati un
tantino controversi anzi la prima scelta
controversa che ho fatta la prima scelta
difficile l'ho fatta me l'hanno
raccontata perché non ero ancora nato ho
scelto di nascere a sette mesi
questo avrebbe potuto complicare un
tantino le cose ma per fortuna sono
ancora qui a raccontarvelo in questi
dieci anni le cose non sono state
proprio facili per me ho vissuto con i
miei nonni gran parte dei primi dieci
anni appunto circa quattro anni della
della mia infanzia li ho passati a casa
dei miei nonni in un paesino sperduto
della romania dove praticamente non
c'era acqua corrente in casa per fare i
bisogni si andava fuori in un giardino e
so che può sembrare una storia strana
raccontata oggi e
quel momento quel momento di felicità e
di gioia mi ha fatto mi ha determinato a
scegliere questo argomento oggi che
penso sia fondamentale un po per tutti
noi perché tutti tolti tutti i fronzoli
tolti gli oggetti tolte le cose che
inseguiamo nella nostra vita a mio modo
di vedere le cose abbiamo due risorse
che sono particolarmente scarse ovvero
energia e tempo
se ci pensiamo tutti noi abbiamo un
tempo limitato
oggi ne abbiamo parlato un po e
paradossalmente passiamo un terzo del
nostro tempo per dormire ricaricare le
energie
eppure molto spesso facciamo l'errore di
trattare queste risorse con sufficienza
come se fossero illimitate per noi e
quindi il ragionamento che vorrei fare
insieme a voi e soprattutto in questa
giornata dove voi avete fatto una scelta
avete scelto di vestirvi di prendere la
macchina il treno qualcuno l'aereo
magari per essere qui perché siete qui
perché avete scelto di utilizzare la
vostra energia e il vostro tempo di oggi
per essere qui penso che sia
fondamentale capire perché facciamo
quello che facciamo capire la ragione
che ci spinge a decidere probabilmente
influenza le azioni che faremo che
influenzeranno i risultati che otterremo
e se ci pensiamo bene la nostra giornata
tipo quello che viviamo in una giornata
tipo è un po la fotografia la miniatura
della nostra vita
ecco venire qui non è stata una scelta
controversa e difficile c'è una storia
che magari qualcuno di voi ha già
sentito di due fratelli due gemelli che
nascono in una famiglia con particolari
difficoltà
il padre un alcolizzato che abusava di
droghe che tornava a casa sempre ubriaco
picchiava la moglie picchiava i due
bambini
insomma la situazione nella quale
nascono crescono e imparano le prime
cose
questi due ragazzi è alquanto difficile
il tempo passa loro diventano
adolescenti il padre addirittura viene
rinchiuso in galera per una delle sue
bravate e loro prendono due strade
totalmente diverse uno di loro diventa
un criminale praticamente alla stregua
del padre la fotocopia l'altro diventa
un avvocato di successo super rispettato
quindi com'è possibile che due persone
così uguali
due persone che hanno vissuto la stessa
situazione stessi insegnamenti stessa
famiglia finiscano e decidano di vivere
un destino così diverso questa è una
scelta un tantino più difficile e
controversa e io sono convinto che le
piccole scelte il modo in cui decidiamo
le piccole cose influenza alla lunga
come decideremo le grandi
ed è proprio qui il ragionamento che
vorrei fare insieme a voi mi hanno
sempre mi hanno sempre detto l'abbiamo
sentito anche oggi e lo sentiamo
spessissimo che i nostri pensieri
generano le nostre parole che poi
portano alle nostre azioni
quindi i nostri risultati sono
direttamente collegati ai nostri
pensieri
l'avete mai sentito questo io mi sono
sempre chiesto quando sentivo questo
questa affermazione ok che cosa
determina i nostri primi pensieri se i
nostri pensieri portano ai nostri
risultati allora che cos'è che determina
i miei primi pensieri e mi sono
appassionato nel mio viaggio in nelle
mie tante scelte controverse vene
racconterò solo un paio mi sono
appassionato di neuroscienze di
neuromarketing quindi ho iniziato ad
approfondire
i membri della nostra mente di come
funziona il nostro cervello e ho
scoperto che i nostri pensieri
i nostri primi pensieri vengono generati
dalle esperienze che viviamo
fin da piccoli ed alle persone che ci
circondano cioè noi impariamo per due
ragioni per due cose emozioni che
viviamo e imitando le persone che ci
circondano infatti pensando poi a quando
ero piccolo aveva senso perché non mi
bastava che mio nonno mia nonna mi
dicesse non toccare il forno per che
scotta dovevo andare lì toccarlo
scottarmi a dire ok dolore non lo voglio
più toccare perché ero piccolo un
bambino non avevo quel pensiero formato
quindi emozioni contro pensieri sono la
dualità con la quale noi decidiamo con
la quale scegliamo di fare le azioni che
facciamo ogni giorno
e qui c'è il trucco che ho scoperto e
quando l'ho scoperto ha cambiato
radicalmente il mio modo di decidere le
piccole cose e anche le grandi cose
nella vita
il trucco è questo le emozioni sono il
linguaggio che utilizza il nostro
inconscio i pensieri sono il linguaggio
che utilizza il nostro cervello
razionale
ecco spiegato il motivo per cui sappiamo
razionalmente talmente tante cose e
hanno senso come ad esempio fumare fa
male come ad esempio fare una
determinata cosa fa male o come ad
esempio banalmente vorrei smetterla di
mangiare schifezze perché voglio
mettermi in forma razionalmente lo
sappiamo ma l'emozione che associamo
invece a quel gesto a quella determinata
cosa a quella determinata azione più
forte è l'emozione contro il pensiero
vince sempre
vince sempre l'emozione quindi vorrei
condividere con voi un metodo che ho
utilizzato e che mi ha aiutato nella mia
vita nella mia esperienza a fare scelte
controverse fare scelte che
considerate folli forti ovvero invece di
pensare invece di prestare attenzione
semplicemente al pensiero alla logica di
prestare attenzione alle nostre emozioni
di chiedersi soprattutto quando avrò 97
anni
che emozione sarò felice
fiero soddisfatto di aver vissuto in
quel determinato momento
ad esempio quando a 27 anni ho deciso di
abbandonare a lasciare il mio lavoro che
era considerato sicuro con tutti i
benefit con la macchina con il telefono
pagato con tutta una serie di cose che i
miei amici dicevano wow sei fortunato e
ho deciso di lasciare tutto per andare a
vivere su un'isola cambiando lavoro per
guadagnare meno inizialmente non sapendo
quale sarebbe stato poi il futuro che mi
aspettava per inseguire la mia passione
il mio sogno ma quando l'ho fatto quando
ho dovuto fare una scelta così forte
contro i miei familiari contro tutti
quelli che mi diceva non è una pazzia
dove vai
cosa ne sarà di te stai lasciando
qualcosa di certo di sicuro per qualcosa
che non sai che cos'è mi sono chiesto di
cosa sarò più fiero quando avrò 97 anni
di aver inseguito mio sogno di aver
fatto una scelta forte di aver fatto una
scelta controversa vuoi di aver giocato
sul sicuro di aver aspettato di essere
stato di fermo e la leaf è stato facile
fare i bagagli e decidere ma come ad
esempio dopo quando a 30 anni ho deciso
di lasciare di nuovo una postazione di
sicurezza e garanzia che avevo raggiunto
in quell azienda per poi decidere di
aprire la mia attività e diventare un
imprenditore nonostante nessuno nella
mia famiglia fosse stato un imprenditore
prima di me quindi ancora una volta cosa
stai facendo
ecco penso che chiedersi fare farsi
queste domande possa darci una risposta
che alla lunga ci renderà soddisfatti e
voglio dedicare questo mio intervento
oggi è una persona è una persona molto
speciale speciale che è mia mamma perché
spesso sono le persone che abbiamo
attorno a noi che ci insegnano come
abbiamo visto le elezioni più forti e
mia mamma mi ha insegnato la lezione più
controversa di tutte non c'è più da poco
più di un anno
e lei nell'ultimo periodo ha sofferto
veramente tanto per una malattia e
nonostante la sofferenza nonostante il
dolore nonostante quello che provava
anche nei suoi ultimi momenti trovava il
modo per pensare a me per pensare ai
miei fratelli per pensare agli altri
trova il mondo il modo per confortare
lei noi e per donarci un sorriso quindi
la lezione più controversa di tutte che
penso ci abbia insegnato è che la
maggior parte dei genitori si concentra
tutta la vita a insegnare a insegnare ai
propri figli come vivere mentre lei ci
ha insegnato come morire
per concludere penso che quello che farà
la differenza quando avremo 97 anni
sarà che emozione avremmo provato che
emozioni avremmo fatto provare chi
avremo ispirato e da chi ci saremmo
fatti ispirare e chi sarà con noi al
capolinea
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no